aujourd'hui celui qui met le feu aux
poudres en disant à faire une réforme
des retraites en trois jours c'est c'est
lui celui qui explique comment envoyer
des immigrés dans les campagnes
c'est lui donc faut qu'il arrête c'est
le président qui provoque cette chenille
qu'il redoute je sais pas à quoi il joue
mais je vois qu'il m'inquiète un peu par
cette façon de de de de continuer à
provoquer le pays mais comme il l'a fait
depuis 5 ans ça fait 5 ans que président
de la République
fracture ce pays d'un côté poussent les
gens de de gauche dans les bras de la
France insoumise se Mélenchon essayer de
radicaliser les électeurs de droite je
peux les pousser dans les bras de Marine
Le Pen pour se poser en camp de
rassurant contre les extrêmes etc c'est
une stratégie de fracturation du pays il
va falloir en sortir parce qu'il ne
ressortira il ne peut rien ressortir de
positif d'une telle fracturation du